i'm going to get going and i want to
give what we thought would be useful is
to give a little bit of the background
of the stanford center for professional
development because we have been
around for a really long time
and
so
it started in the 50s with fred turman
who was the dean of engineering at the
time
uh and he is also considered somewhat
the father of silicon valley so he had
this idea that it was important for
working engineers in the area to be able
to continue
their study of engineering
while continuing to work and so he
founded the hcp program or the honors
cooperative program
which continues today he founded that in
the 50s and what this was as i said is a
way for mostly local companies and
people working at local companies in the
bay area to continue their advanced
studies part on a part-time basis with
stanford and so obviously how those
courses were delivered has changed a lot
over the years and in the beginning it
was we had a a television network that
was literally broadcasting to companies
within a 50 mile radius of stanford and
so people would you know
go watch tv with some of their
colleagues and and follow along with the
lectures and then assignments would be
mailed out or hand delivered and in some
cases they would come on campus to to
take actual courses if they have that
ability
that obviously evolved a lot over the
years and it went from a broadcast
network to a satellite network and then
of course in the 90s it began to move
online to the internet and by the late
90s i believe we were delivering our
first fully online master's degree
through electrical engineering through
the internet and of course it's evolved
a lot from that since and i think
starting in the the
early 2000s we stopped broadcasting over
television networks or satellite
networks and now it's a hundred percent
online and so today everything is
delivered over the internet but
it's it is a really interesting and long
history and the other thing i'll say is
that in addition to the hcp
hep students these honors cooperative or
part-time master's students we also have
non-degree students so these are we'll
talk about this in a little bit more
detail these are students potentially
like you who are working professionals
who are not applying for a degree at
stanford but are interested in taking a
single course or a few courses just to
fill gaps in their knowledge or to
pursue an accredited graduate
certificate and we'll talk a little bit
more about that opportunity
now obviously with the move online we've
also evolved the kinds of offerings we
we we can provide to learners around the
globe and so this is a kind of a brief
overview of some of the offerings we're
really going to be just talking about
those
on the on the end there in the yellow
and gray
but in addition to those credit bearing
we have offerings for professional
learners that are more probably what you
think of when you think of online
learning these days so these would be
self-paced classes maybe each course is
six to ten hours and you put together
four or five of them to earn a
professional certificate it's not for
academic credit it's very usually
self-paced um and and sometimes it's
something that you would do maybe with
some of your colleagues
at work and so these could be things
like product management i see i saw a
question about the the genomics program
so we have a course on genetics as well
and so these are generally produced by
these are produced
the content is created in collaboration
with stanford faculty
and these are usually on
cutting edge topics but they're not
they're for the most part they're not
graduate they're not of the same rigor
as the graduate courses uh these are are
really designed for working
professionals who need to just fill a
small gap um or
or uh update a soft skill
what we'll be talking more about today
are these credit bearing programs um and
john jonathan and i will be repeating
this is
the this is a really unique opportunity
at through stanford so this is not an
extension program these are the same
classes and so again this yellow you
have the opportunity to take individual
classes through uh through at stanford
remotely alongside the on-campus
students and you would earn a stanford
transcript and if you take several of
those courses you could earn a a
credited cert graduate or undergraduate
certificate
in addition to that as i mentioned and
this is really where this whole thing
began as we do stanford the school of
engineering does offer some degrees that
you can complete part-time and or
remotely so we'll go in a little bit
more detail about this not every we do
not offer the full portfolio of stanford
classes school of engineering classes
online it's always a select a smaller
subset of those but there are some
degrees that you could complete
fully online if you carefully sort of
plan your program of study
so i'm sure you i see there already a
lot of questions uh coming in um
and uh and and i'll we'll get to those
at the end but i do
want to give a little bit more detail on
how these credit bearing courses work
and we can't come back to some of those
professional programs i see a few
questions that come in happy to answer
some questions about those as well
so
these are again i want to emphasize this
is non-accession program these are the
same classes not even the same material
literally the same class so the course
is scheduled in one of uh in one of the
rooms on stanford's campus that have
cameras built into it and the lectures
are recorded then they're posted to our
learning management system and the
expectation for remote workers for
working professionals who wouldn't be
able to attend the the lectures live
anyway is that they would watch those
lectures at their convenience you can
live stream it but in most cases there's
not two-way audio and video with the
lecture classroom
uh in some cases there is but in most
cases there isn't and the reason being
is that
we we have created this program with
working professionals in mind and even
though this is often requested very few
students are able to take advantage of
that because maybe you have a job nine
to five or you're in a very different
time zone
so you would watch those lectures at
your convenience you would follow along
with the class you're going to be
following a 10-week quarter right
because it's stanford does you would
attend office hours online so how many
office hours are online will depend on
the size of the class a really big
lecture class with lots of tas will be
able to offer more sessions uh online um
a smaller class may only have an
instructor an ota in which case it may
be by appointment only all your
assignments would be able to be
submitted online through various
platforms you would have access to
discussion boards like
piazza or ed discussion or slack or
something like that to allow you to
connect with the teaching team and other
students we also have a dedicated slack
channel for for our students where you
wouldn't ask course questions but you
could ask logistical questions
and then for exams you would nominate an
exam monitor
this would be
someone like
a if you're if you're working and you're
coming into the office in most cases
it'd be something like an hr
representative or supervisor
if you aren't coming into the office it
could be something like a local library
or a local university or community
college that might offer a testing
service so if it's someone at work then
likely you'd be able to do that you know
for free uh if you're if it's if you
have to rely on it on a service then
there will likely be an additional
charge that would be to that service and
it's not part of kind of what we're
talking about uh
when we get to tuition at the end
it is important that that exam that exam
monitor is someone who can deliver that
exam to you in person the goal is to
recreate as closely as possible the
experience that students on campus are
having right and they would be
responsible for making sure you you are
aware of the stanford's honor code and
the rules for the exam and that you're
following the time uh the time limits um
but they would want you to do that in
person then we would coordinate with
them to get the exam from them
and finally how are you accessing all
this stuff for the quarter that you're
enrolled you do receive a stanford email
and login credentials that allows you to
access all these resources in addition
to electronic resources through the
library
that email and login credentials are
only active during the quarter you're
enrolled uh and we'll go over a little
bit in more detail but you don't have to
be continuously enrolled if you're
pursuing a certificate so if you were
taking a class this summer and then
decided you needed to wait two quarters
and take another one in the spring your
your your email and credentials would be
inactive in between
um i i think that's the kind of core
about how these courses work i'm going
to look through the questions as john
presents i'm sure there are a lot of
questions about the kind of logistics i
do just again want to emphasize that
these are the same courses it's not an
extension program that's really an
opportunity and it is also a challenge
and i know jonathan is going to repeat
this so i i think it's an important
thing to mention again and again because
it's a huge opportunity because there
really aren't many programs like this
where you can take you are taking the
same class uh that is happening on
campus and you can do this without
having to go through the full
complicated admission process to being
admitted as a master's student but it is
not for everybody because one these
classes are most of the students in
these classes are going to be full-time
students and they're going to be able to
dedicate almost 100 of their time to
their studies you are going to be
working at the same time most likely
you're going to be working and may not
have that time you're going to be
juggling a lot of other priorities that
can be a real challenge um
some some learners don't want you know
kind of the full rigorous deep
foundational or theoretical knowledge
that's not what they need so they're
more interested in maybe just learning
the latest tool for machine learning
whereas these courses really are
academic graduate level courses and in
some cases the higher level really for
phd students where you're
kind of learning the theoretical or
foundational underpinnings of what
you're doing you really you know if
you're going to take a machine learning
or even some of our computer science
courses you're probably other computer
science courses you're probably going to
be writing proofs you're going to
probably really be digging into the
mathematical foundation so um we find
that there are a lot of learners
who often our learners are people who
are already doing this work at their
companies
um
but they don't have the theoretical
foundation so they're really coming back
to get that deeper understanding so they
can apply that to the work that they're
doing
um similarly we we see a lot of people
who are working programmers but maybe
they have a background in math and
they're self-taught in programming or
they're taking one or two courses and
now they really want to flesh that out
because this is what they're doing
professionally and they're not
interested in going back to get a
master's they just need to fill a few
gaps we have a lot of people who are
have phds already but they finished it
15 years ago and some of this research
and these classes weren't available when
they were pursuing their masters of
their phd and now they're coming back to
fill in that gap but again it's not for
everybody they're very rigorous classes
um that you're alongside full-time
students which can be a challenge it's
going to be on a quarter system
but for many people this is a huge and
really rare opportunity and so with that
i'm gonna hand it off uh to jonathan
and uh john i'm gonna jump it to the
next slide and here we go
that's great thank you pax um good
morning everybody and welcome to
the graduate courses and programs
information session
my name is jonathan noble i'm the senior
director of student um services at
stanford center for professional
department um i've been at stanford 15
years approximately and so i have a
great deal of knowledge in each of the
programs
and courses that offer including
the application process and some of the
things that you know good intonation
what would be considered
important for you to know about boxes
and problems and how you can be
successful
in that respect
so one of the things i wanted to quickly
mention is you know talking back backing
on to what pax was saying you know
this is a unique opportunity this is
these are world-class faculty
world-class courses and there's not very
many universities that offer the
opportunity particularly for what we
call the non-degree program for students
to almost you know we have maybe
completed your undergraduate education
you may be considering some graduate
programs on courses and to to kind of
dive in and and almost test drive um a
number of courses without committing to
a part-time product obviously to do so
you need to apply and qualify to either
take into these courses or programs
because they are credit bearing having
said that their application process is
not just requests but i'll come up to
that second
so some of the key considerations for
successful
um most important things that we say to
students who are prospective students or
applicants who are thinking about uh
taking subcourses coming up um it's know
about your key definition you know we're
on a quarter system stanford works for
quarter system 10 weeks and the pace of
each particular quarter is it's kind of
fast compared to the normal semester
system that you may be used to so it's
important to know obviously the key that
is when to enroll when instruction
starts
when you may be able to drop out of a
course you know when your exams are when
your homework deadlines are so those are
kind of the obvious things like make
sure that if you are considering courses
and programs that you prepare yourself
for the rigor
or an academic court and be aware but
deadlines are kind of thick and fast if
you need to if you are a working
professional feel better
you know prepare yourself for
approximately 15 to 25 hours of post
work per week those courses can be a
little less than that sometimes
fill over that i think the most
important thing to kind of get an
understanding of
commitment that you
need to to to undertake each each week
or on the course that you may select is
to really dig in and have a look at the
course of us maybe have a look at some
um you know some samples of courses that
have been completed in the past so you
kind of get an understanding you know as
always reach out to us we can really
give you a good idea of you know how
many lectures you'll have information
sessions you know the structure of the
homework exams um and just the general
rigor that you'll you'll have to
undertake certainly as you're working
professionally you know you want to make
sure that you can commit to this and be
successful
what's also important as well is if you
are a working professional i'm very busy
and you're thinking about taking some
courses or programs because you know
make sure that you have that support
network in place you know whether it's
through co-workers or your manager
through your family you know if you are
committing to the time required list
please make sure that you have the
support infrastructure in place so that
you can adequately and
do service of course that you're taking
and be successful the last thing that we
want is you to be overwhelmed not have a
good experience but just make sure that
you
know what you are committed to and that
you're able to do it so it's like
checking the boxes yes i think at the
time yes quite supportive yes i
understand the amount of hours of
coursework required so these are things
that you you know you must go through
that you know
what you're committed to
um and then obviously
what i think is important as well is if
you can and at the time is attending
quarterly online orientations and social
fixes these are valuable valuable
resources where you can really get a
good idea of what it's like to study at
a distance what it's like to take a
stanford course what it's like to you
know to work through a quarter system
that you may not have been experienced
before and then and listen to and
understand from not only staff but
students that are actually currently
students and know exactly how these
problems and courses work and can give
you some valuable insights into what it
takes to be successful and enjoy the
course
so we move to the next slide
okay so as i mentioned a little earlier
on there's pac-step as well we have two
graduate programs one's called the
non-degree program what we call ndo and
the other is called the honors
cooperative program hcp now the first
one a non-degree
program is as it says it's you're not
committing to a degree it's your ability
to either take individual courses of
credit or courses towards a graduate
certificate i'll talk a little bit about
each one
so when you're applying for the
non-degree program that you as i said
taking individual courses for a sequence
of courses that might lead to a
certificate
there you would be considered a
non-degree or not matriculated student
you would apply during any quarter you
don't have to apply in the fall you can
take or apply during any of the four
academic quarters being ordered with
spring and stuff so there's no need for
you to wait for a
academic quarter to apply
very simple applications online it's not
as rigorous as a full-time degree
application it's basically
completing a little bit of information
about your background academic
professional state purpose and then
providing things like transcripts that
we can see if you're a good fit
qualified to take serve courses
obviously as i mentioned these are
credit bearing courses and so there is a
application review process
um with applications you obviously have
to meet the stated requirements um so
each course is different they will have
certain specific application
requirements some will just require an
undergraduate degree with a certain
grade point average taken in a certain
discipline some courses will require
that plus prerequisites because they
know because people know what you need
to have in your in your in your locker
to be successful
um
again it's a flexible uh application
system so you can apply at any point in
time
you can if you take courses in between
you know you might take a course during
autumn and jump back in and spring if
you take other things you can we can be
flexible and update your application
and we're what you call and
we describe you as a non-continuous
people so as you're taking courses we're
taking your application and applying
that to each one that you select so it's
not a case if you're applying and then
you're getting black approval for every
course you take it doesn't look like
that your application is reviewed for
each course you select you don't need to
submit an application for each one once
you submitted it once we have disputes
but we will reflect upon the activities
that you take and there is a review
process for each one
so uh we also in the non-degree uh
option program we have something called
graduate certificates
these are accredited non-degree programs
as i mentioned few minutes ago they're
typically three four or five courses you
need to complete any sequence
or in a depth or area it might be
artificial intelligence
a similar subject
that will lead to a certificate
or a credential once you complete it now
with the graduate certificates as i said
you know
certain number of courses they be called
they can be elected depending on which
of the graduate certificates that you
selected want to pursue
um but the the common denominator
amongst all graduate certificates is you
must maintain a b or better in each
course okay so to be successful and
also welcome to the program and qualify
for the writing certificate you must
detain the b or better each course
with the graduate certificate have up to
three years to complete um again
typically three four five courses and
which probably you select uh you know we
are mindful that you're working
professionally may need to take water
off here or there uh if you're not
required to enroll every quality you
could take break but you do have a
maximum three years to complete the
program
if you do complete the program you'll
get a fee event in every course complete
all the call and collective requirements
again 50 45 courses you complete the
certificate you get that you can
conclude
that
and i think that one of the best
benefits apart from gaining an insight
into stanford education at graduate
level and experiencing world-class
faculty and content
um if this program is unique in that if
you um complete successfully complete
courses get required grades
you can transfer up to a maximum maximum
of 18 units of credit from the
non-degree program to the degree program
whether it's part-time or full-time you
can transfer that
but there is one caveat you have to
apply and be accepted into the program
first it's not assured it does not
guarantee you entry into the degree
program if you apply are accepted and
you have those 18 units of credits in
your back pocket you can potentially
transfer to qualified degree okay that i
think is a very unique uh you know uh
component of this of this program
could be run through the honors
cooperative program um developed as pax
said back in the 1950s
uh through fredericton dean of
engineering the honors cooperative
program is basically a part-time
attribute
it's your ability as a working
professional to undertake through the
and so i'll take talk a little bit about
that um so when you're applying you
apply as you would for a normal
full-time degree through the graduate
admissions office it's no different
the difference with the program is that
you're studying at a part-time basis not
full-time
but once you apply you do apply to the
office of graduate commissions and
depending on which degree you want to
undertake the application is there um
through to the academic department so if
you're thinking about maybe a computer
science degree a graduate degree then
that would be
to computer science department for
review
but the department will check the
details and everything um you know for
your application and then obviously
feedback to you uh if you have been
successful
what i would encourage you to do if you
are considering applying is um obviously
go on to the stanford website check out
the public top which you will be
applying make sure you have to figure
out yourself the details of the program
the deadlines for application set the
last thing we want you to do is apply
and then you know
feel that it's not good fit for you so
really do your research go on to the
academic department's website look
through all the information
look through the deadlines and again as
pax said you know if you want help if
you want support in choosing getting
information for a free program whatever
it is reach out to me myself and my team
will be more than happy to help you
we're very experienced at each of these
defeats we can really guide you
ultimately the decision is yours but we
can help
you know
um
john himself
i think your audio is cutting in and out
a little bit um do you mind if i i take
over a little bit from here and then you
know
yeah so yeah i just wanted to repeat a
few things and actually john maybe we
can also just answer some i think there
are a lot of questions coming in um that
we maybe we can just pause here for a
little bit and work through some of
these as well so
um
some people have asked about the
requirements for the non-degree program
so thank you for asking about them and
next time we'll definitely add these to
this side they're available on our
website but you do need a bachelor's
degree and you need a minimum gpa that
minimum gpa
will it varies by department so each
department so a mechanical engineering
class has a different minimum gpa than a
cs class for computer science i think
it's 3.0 uh in a university degree and
then you just need to meet the
prerequisites for those classes as well
and so that's really what they're
looking for and i know john said a lot
of this i'm just repeating it um
and so it you know you'll be they'll
look to make sure you meet those
prerequisites some courses don't have
prerequisites beyond that university
degree and a minimum gpa but of course
some of them will have more strict uh
you will have prerequisites like you
know common ones or linear algebra or
multi-variable calculus or some
programming backboard background
we uh and all those gpa requirements
will be listed on the course as well as
the certificate pages so you can go on
to our site if you're looking interested
in what what is there
we had a few questions good questions
about interactions with the professors
so and about coming uh coming to campus
so let me say the interaction with
professor that that's going to depend a
lot on the class i'm sure you've taken
classes at a university and if you're in
a thousand person lecture which some of
them are that big there's not it's
harder to reach the professor because
you're competing with a thousand other
students uh in some of the smaller
classes however where there are 30 or 40
students that the the faculty member
will be running the you know the the the
office hours and there will be plenty of
opportunities so it's going to depend on
the size of the class um
and so for that in terms of coming in
person if you are local
i want to put an asterisk on what i say
because the last two years have been
very different and it's possible that
that will also there may be changes in
the future uh given sort of the new
state of the world in many regards but
in general you can come on campus for
office hours if you're local so if you
wanted to attend in-person office hours
and you can come on campus for some
resources
generally if you wanted to come on
campus for instance to attend a lecture
or to to attend if you need if a class
had an optional lab that was only
available in person that would need to
be you would need faculty permission for
that and in many cases you you can't do
it because the the seats are very
limited and they don't make they have to
give priority to the residential
students so that really that can vary um
again i put an asterisk in that because
that's changed a lot i will add actually
one important detail that if you're
local and you're planning on coming on
campus more than three times in a
quarter the university is asking that
you uh upload your vaccine information
into the system so in terms of cobin 19
so that's also an important thing to
know they would be an expectation that
you would be
vaccinated
in terms of
the master's degrees again i know john
was already covering this and and john
i'll pause in a second and let you uh
add some more information those
admissions processes processes are
through the the pro the departments
themselves so i see questions about gre
and toefl those are really going to
depend on the individual department
requirements so i'd encourage you to go
there and see those the admissions is
not through us for the honors
cooperative program
for the non-degree program gre is toyful
those aren't required we just need to
see your your your undergraduate or
graduate transcripts know know that
you're um you're meeting the
prerequisites uh the general and the
specific prerequisites for the courses
these are open to students around the
world both the master's degrees and the
non-degrees
program so you don't have to be local
you don't have to be in the u.s
for the master's programs
we saw some questions about can i do
some of it online and some of it in
person in most cases yes again
departments have slightly different
policies about how you transfer between
if you start if you start part-time and
remote how you would transfer back to
full-time or if you start full-time how
you would move on to being part-time in
most cases there is flexibility which is
is fantastic right so if you start
full-time residential and then you need
to move uh to part-time uh that's a real
um you know that can because you got a
job that's a real opportunity or if
you're working and you want to work for
a year and then come on campus to do it
full-time again that's an option in most
cases i would check with the individual
department uh for for details about what
you need to do in order to make that
transfer if you can make the transfer
how often and i want to repeat as well
as that these this program is not
available for all master's degrees at
stanford uh for the most part what we're
talking about are school of engineering
programs and in terms of the course the
programs that you could potentially
complete fully online they're really
only five that i would say you can
comfortably complete and that are
accredited for fully distance education
those would be computer science
electrical engineering management
science and engineering chemical
engineering and biomedical informatics
and in those cases again
not every course is available uh
remotely to learners so you would also
have to plan as john emphasized you'd
have to plan your program plan carefully
both with the department and probably
with us to understand what your options
are john did you want to uh jump in or
or add anything to that
no i think you could capture that
correctly um i think it's important that
you know again as i say at the top of
the conversation that you you are aware
when you find
what's required tips of uh not just the
application process but any additional
information and where it applies as tax
mentioned tokyo and grb um again reach
out to my team we can guide you on that
but we want to make sure that you're
aware of what you need to undertake to
submit an application and certainly
making sure you select the right program
and the right modality that will see
circumstances
thanks john um and let me see if i'm
just looking through some of the other
questions we'll we'll talk about tuition
so
in terms of the class size is going to
vary greatly
you can go to
explore courses maybe we can post that
as well so that will give you a general
class size for all stanford classes not
the ones that are offered through scpd
in terms of looking at what are
available remotely you would want to go
to our site and see what the options are
and then probably talk to us because
when those are offered varies a lot year
to year and we try to set that that
schedule up a year in advance after the
departments have set up their schedules
um
in terms of if you pursue a job
jonathan had already addressed this but
if you pursue graduate courses through
the non-degree program up to 18 units
can be applied to a master's degree if
you're accepted into the master's
program
um and
and they have to be applicable of course
to the degree so it would you could for
instance um
if the core for instance computer
science master's degree if you there's a
core requirements that can be satisfied
uh if you've taken them at stanford so
you could pursue those and take them
through the non-degree program and then
they would you know you wouldn't have to
do them again as part of your master's
degree
but again only 18 units of those so you
could for instance if you completed 20
units of course work to satisfy those
four courses you would have satisfied
those four courses but you would only
get 18 of those units to count towards
what i believe is and i would double
check 45 units to earn the master's
program
um jonathan is anything else you would
want to add there
no no we're good
thank you
then maybe i'll move um do you want to
talk a little bit about uh tuition sure
yes i could do that
um so uh for academic year 2223 you know
if you are considering enrolling in the
non-degree program
um the
changed at tuition
to say
academic year 2223 it's 1352 per unit of
credit now that's not per pulse that's
per unit of credit so if you're
undertaking the four unit course that's
a total of 5 408
obviously the the tuition includes you
know access to materials access to you
know the calls um
it doesn't require any additional
expense in your part unless you really
wanted to purchase textbooks that might
aid you etc
um in terms of a graduate certificate if
you were to look at that as an option
you'd have to take three four five
courses whatever it is that's required
for what you'd like to take it's usually
between 12 to 20 units to complete this
certificate so you should present that
expense of the tuition expense for that
particular uh certificate again we want
to let you know this situation because
you know if you are planning on a budget
or what kind of uh expense that you need
to infer
uh for for these courses then you're
aware of that i know a lot of you um
seek you know reimbursement to your
employers we want to let you know what
the cost is and some of you may have a
full tuition benefits plans for
employers so at least you were able to
have that discussion with them to plan
uh the budget for you and taking courses
uh for academic year 2223.
um in terms of tuition for the degree
programs again um we've got you know um
three that we could talk about it i
think a future date but uh three kind of
bands of tuition uh depending on how
many courses how many credits you take
so it's kind of a little bit different
than what we're discussing right now and
again you know the tuition for
the degree program also varies on
whether you're a part-time program
obviously the higher workload you take
the higher tuition
um we just wanted to kind of give you a
quick insight into what you should
expect in terms of tuition if you're
planning courses 22 20.
okay
thanks jonathan i'm going to jump back
to this earlier slide just because it
they were still getting a couple
questions
um
so uh in terms of the the um
the
graduate certificates there are
questions if i meet the prerequisites
can i expect to get a seat um it'll so
yes if if you meet the prerequisites you
apply and there's a seat available the
expectations that you should be able to
take take take the class right there can
be exceptions to that and classes can
close there can be limited seats um
you know etc etc you're not admitted
into a graduate certificate per se your
application will then be reviewed it's
reviewed on a course by course basis so
you're approved to take courses is a
better way to to think about it so you
would take a single course then you
would take another course and they would
review your your your application again
your transcripts and see if you meet the
prerequisites someone asked you know
they had a master's degree but no
transcript uh would you know would that
still be allow them to take it you would
we would ask you to submit your
undergraduate transcripts uh so we can
verify those and then there's an
opportunity in the application to
explain any additional work you've done
whether that's professional self-study
or a research program and then that is
also forwarded along to the department
so that if there's additional context
for them to understand yeah i don't i
don't have the specific uh requirement
for python programming as an
undergraduate but i've been working for
seven years as a python programmer or
something like that and so i i feel like
i strongly meet this requirement and
they would take that into consideration
once you've begun successfully
completing classes they'll also of
course take into consideration your past
performance in classes and in terms of
uh approving you for the next class
um
let's hear uh i i see another question
here pax on um what's the difference
between accredited variant courses and
courses in the graduate certificate and
essentially nothing they're the same um
it's just your ability
uh credit bearing courses you can take
on an individual basis that's just your
ability to opportunity to take digital
courses that might be of interest to you
uh
for you know specific reason whereas
courses you take within the graduate
certificate program are in a specific
focused area
but it essentially in general terms
they're the same that the credit bearing
they
have the same
rigor and the same homework
assignments and exams so they really are
no different
somebody else also asked what's the
difference between
uh a graduate certificate and
professional certificate well we are
focusing on graduate significance today
but i will say the difference is that
threshold certificates are not credit
bearing
they don't require you to follow the 10
week academic quarter
and
you know these professional certificates
are typically pre-recorded and they're
self-fixed so while they we do have
overlaps in you know artificial
intelligence grant get for example a
professional certificate they are quite
different one is called obvious it's not
one is great very well it's not so they
are quite different um
that one other question before i head
back to pax we had somebody ask can
tuition be
covered by staff given strp funds uh
that's a problem at stanford yes they
can be certainly the non-degree program
and the great uh certificate as well as
the degree program are all covered by
strp but what i would encourage you to
do is to contact that particular office
and discuss what you might be thinking
in terms of taking courses and programs
thanks jonathan um we had a just a
a couple other questions that come in
that i want to address um
most classes are three to five units um
computer science classes if your
non-degree must a lot of them are
variable units if you're a non-degree
student in the computer for the computer
science classes they must be taken at
the maximum units that is what they see
as the is the actual units of work
that's required
um
in terms of uh in terms of if you do the
non-degree or you do a graduate
certificate you apply for a master's
program you are um
there you are in the same um
you are in the same admissions pool as
all the other students who are applying
for the master's degree so it doesn't
give you a special special edge in that
way but
it will be taken into consideration
you'll be able to submit a stanford
transcript you may have relationships
with some of the professors if you've
taken courses and that's been
available so that it's it's not like you
go into a separate pool and you're
considered separately you're in the same
pool and of course these are incredibly
competitive master's programs
but we do have plenty of students who
have
started as nbo students and moved on to
either a master's or even a phd program
down the line and it was an opportunity
for again for them to test it out to get
a sense of of what whether the graduate
study or whether
stanford would be right for them um if
they were admitted
and maybe to just get their feet on the
ground if they've been out of school for
a while maybe make some connections with
new faculty and uh and just remember
what it's like to be in uh in in the
university we we had a question if you
are pursuing or you you declare an
interest in a particular graduate
certificate you're not locked into that
graduate certificate you you don't have
to come you have i think three years to
complete the courses in that graduate
certificate um and by the way you could
complete if you completed all those
courses in three years and then you you
could then tell us hey i've completed
these courses i'm interested in the
graduate certificate and we can then
sort of apply if you've completed the
requirements you would get the graduate
certificate but you're not locked in so
we have students who declare for a
certificate take one course and then
decide you know what i just want to take
individual courses and they can take
again any course that there uh there's a
seat available and they meet the
prerequisites they would then um you
know they would be able to take those
courses
uh so you're not locked into a
certificate program it's not like a
degree program you're not admitted into
it it's really when you if when you
apply and you select what you're
interested in it's more a declaration of
interest and that allows us to track
your progress to send you as new courses
are added whereas courses become
available for that certificate
we allow you we allows us to communicate
that to you but it's it's not like
applying to a degree program where
you're locked into a program um and you
know you have to uh follow it through
um we have a question here pax which we
get quite a lot
usually on a daily basis and i want to
address it
and i want to say this applies to a lot
of the degree programs our question was
can
i complete a stanford computer science
graduate free online
that's a good question it's
not an easy answer to give but that
really depends on which degree uh
specialization you select and which
courses you select so there really is an
easy answer to that
you know um if you pick a certain
specialization of your defines
it may not be possibly completed online
because the structure of forces uh might
require maps etc um having said that
there are specializations that are more
intuitive for online study
and again you know the stanford degree
please realize that you have a depth of
breadth areas and so when you work with
the academic department on your degree
program plan
and select
is entirely based on that so it really
is um it's possible but it really
depends on the specialization you pick
which courses you pick so uh that's the
only um
that's the best answer we can give to
that question
and i just want to repeat that's for
degree programs for master's programs
all the graduate certificates can be
completed completely online right those
are fully online and for and and we are
working because this has actually come
up amazingly you'd think everything's
been online for a while but um
we are working with the departments now
to better communicate which depth areas
and concentrations in particular
programs can be completed fully online
right and so again
and even when you can complete that
depth area fully online there are
probably a lot of classes that you
cannot complete right you're going to
have a subset of the full classes in
that depth area so we're working on
providing more information working
closely with the departments to make
that possible so you have a much better
insight into it um but also
go forward
no it's going to say another good
question just have pax is um again get
asked a lot about this um you know do
you provide a
gpa transcript as well specifically
because yes if it's a credit bearing
course or if it's a graduate certificate
you will get a standard transcript
including courses you complete the
grades you get and the gpa you get so
that is all uh provided
through the non-degree program as well
as the
groups yes you get that
so just i think you broke up a little
bit just just to repeat that you if you
take a credit bearing certificate course
you are earning a stanford transcript
with a grade right you will have a
stanford transcript it'll say cs109 you
know what what your grade etc and so of
course
though you know it is academic credit
and is potentially transferable to other
universities as well that'll depend on
those universities policies but it you
know within stanford it would be if
you're admitted to a program up to 18
units towards a master's program but
these are the credit bearing courses you
are earning a stanford transcript um
let's hear um i'm i see there are a
couple others um
uh let's i just so let me pause here any
specific questions about the yeah i see
a question about if you have a master's
in another program could you apply in cs
i would take a look at cs's page right
and in terms of application deadlines
for master's degrees programs those will
all be set by the department uh they can
vary a little bit some departments have
different
different deadlines for the non-degree
option you can
essentially fill out the application at
any time but again that application
isn't reviewed until you enroll in your
first course right so really you can
start
taking courses any quarter that we're
offering a course that you
um that you are approved for so this
summer and i'll
that we have registration that's open
for the summer right now we have a a
much smaller selection of classes than
usual because that's summer is much our
smallest quarter and you should see a
link there that you can click on to see
what's available this summer
um
yeah so those um
you know you can just you could if you
have time you could apply for that this
week or tonight or whatever and then
then your your your application would be
sent to the department they would review
it if you meet the prerequisites they
would approve you for the class you'd
get a seat in the course you'd um have
you do have i think it's two to three
weeks at the beginning of the quarter
where you can drop the course if you
realize well i'm really not prepared for
this or this is way too much work for me
uh you have a time to drop the course um
and jonathan there is a drop fee if you
do it within those first uh two to three
weeks i think it's a hundred dollars but
your tuition funds would be refunded um
and you wouldn't have anything show up
on your right you just wouldn't get a
transcript
so
you know there would be no withdrawal or
drop or something indicated on your
transcript
um
let me see here uh
we've got a lot more questions coming in
we're reaching about the end of time we
have some really good suggestions about
how to do this better next time i'm glad
that a lot of people have found it
useful and we will uh we'll work on
improving it um and uh we will also it
sounds like there's some people would
love to have more department specific
information we'll see if we can do that
um we have a question about mba program
uh stanford's
master's in business administration i
don't
it's not available online what we what
is available what you can pursue
or take classes online for our the gsb
the graduate school business through
stanford does have some executive and
professional courses that are available
online and the management science and
engineering department within the school
of engineering
does have classes that you can take
online and their master's degree is a
one that you can do through the hcp
program either part-time and or online
um
that's here um if and again i want maybe
one thing to point out for the master's
program yes in this session is being
recorded we'll send out a recording of
this uh we will be doing another version
of the session later this was kind of a
first draft we really appreciate also
we're getting a lot of feedback on how
to improve that please send those in
we'll be doing another another session
of this
um
let me see here uh we got a question
about
uh
courses that you contend in person again
this you know what makes this most of
these courses for non-degree students
are just the expectations you would be
doing it remotely right that is the
expectation um and that the reason that
is is just that's what makes this
program available to us
let me see here and and so that's what
makes it available if you're an honors
cooperative program student if you're a
part-time master's student you're a
fully matriculated student and if you're
in the valley uh i think with very few
exceptions you can just come on campus
for any course right so you don't you
can't take any course in person the
number of online courses that you can
take are not greater it's the same the
ones that are available to non-degree
students but you you are you're not
you're enrolling through stanford's
access system so you would be able to
take in-person courses right and that
actually is how that program used to
really work when it was very much
located in the bay area is people would
come on campus to take additional
courses to fill it out maybe it's a lab
course that just can't be held online
um
and and i see a question about summer
quarter summer quarter is uh shorter
it's eight weeks it is a little bit and
therefore it's the same material so it's
a little bit more intense so that's
something to keep in mind that's a great
question we had an earlier question we
had mentioned that it's 10 to 25 hours
uh a week that's per court or 15 to 25
hours per week that's per course right
these are
really like a part-time job and there
are others that are less intensive but
for the most part um
you know especially when you get to the
upper division 200 level courses they're
they're a lot of work uh there really
are a lot of work um and we and
especially if you're rusty on the
prerequisites you may end up spending a
lot more time you know reviewing your
probability theory or reviewing your
your linear algebra or proof writing or
something like that so it is these are
a very intensive programs
we won't make the slides available
but but this recording will be available
and the slides are you know essentially
embedded in it
the graduate courses constitute
yes so the graduate certificates are so
you would take
you take individual graduate courses if
you take three or four of these within a
specialty that that is part of one of
our graduate certificates then uh you
would earn the certificate so that
they're all four credit courses you're
earning a transcript um the graduate
certificates are credited they're
non-degree programs
uh is there an age limit to take courses
uh you you do need a bachelor's degree
so i think that's it um
you know that's really kind of the the
cut off
sample class is great question i think
we have a link out to cs229 you cannot
audit classes uh through the non-degree
program however you honor the stanford
online youtube channel you can see
recordings of a lot of the lectures so
if you're interested in what those what
those lectures look like if you're
interested in the quality of the
lectures and and the content those are
all freely available and we have those
mostly for
the artificial intelligence program
so cs2 machine learning reinforcement
learning natural language processing
natural language understanding
meta meta learning those are all
courses that are available
online that the lectures are available
online at stanford online so you can
just go and watch those lectures
um
probability and linear algebra uh so we
don't offer any linear algebra uh we we
can give you provide you specific
recommendations there is a probability
course computer science for prop for cs
109 which is probability for computer
science uh which would be a good if
you're interested in taking a course in
probability otherwise uh we can make
individual recommendations
um
all right hacks i hope i apologize for
my audio issues i hope you can hear me
better now um there is a question about
whether um individuals who qualify for
certain programs um it's best to reach
out to us in person um via email um
after one of our contact forms on our
website we'll be able to help you
understand uh what you will
not qualify for so it's best to be
checked for signing
uh thanks thanks jonathan um and there's
a specific question there's a free
internet of things course there's no
longer a certificate that's issued for
that so that should be clear hopefully
on the course itself
that's just a free course it's more like
our professional courses it's it's just
a self-paced course um
if you took the actual um if you took
the actual course with
professor tabaji on the internet of
things you wouldn't get a certificate
for a single course you would get the
certificate if you completed that as
part of a larger certificate program you
would earn a transcript for taking that
single course
um there's an excellent question pax i
think that's worth um
discussing real quick there was a
question about somebody who had taken
prerequisites a while ago when it's been
some time you know what would be
required well um if you have a record of
the prerequisites academically then that
qualifies you but if it's been a while
since you took the topic out it may well
be just beneficial to just do a quick
maybe online brush up both uh just to
kind of re-familiarize yourself with the
materials of prerequisites that you may
have taken a while ago that would be my
best advice
yeah um and then we have a a question
about other other opportunities
especially software development outside
of data science machine learning there
are a lot out there i would take a look
at the computer science we have the most
support there most courses are offered
through there so foundations in computer
science they're advanced and and they're
software systems advanced software
systems there's cyber security there's
databases so all of those um i would
just take a look at the the offerings
there there's quite a bit of computer
science classes
um
the uh the free course is how how are
free courses in preparing for taking a
paid graduate or professional course
um
that's a good question so i think
if you don't the the ones the ones that
we offer like the free ones we offer i
do i think if you don't already have a
strong programming background they're
probably not gonna help you they're
gonna they're going to give you
an interesting background
but they won't be as technical they
won't prepare you for the programming we
do have some professional artificial
intelligence courses a professional
program in ai that are based on the
graduate courses those are very uh
rigorous those are also probably a 10 to
15 hour commitment a week
and those are ones you
you know that you could you could look
at they're very different program and we
see we're getting questions about other
informational sessions we'll probably
plan some that cover other um
other uh other um
that will cover some of the other topic
areas i see just a question about
coursera etc as meeting a prerequisite
you know it's really going to depend on
the department and and who's reviewing
it it's really hard for us to say for
certain uh you know my general sense is
if you wanted you could probably you
know people asked about the foundations
in cs
you know there are a lot of ways to to
cover the foundations in computer
science uh you know just the the kind of
first two quarters of programming those
could be done through a community
college maybe cs106a could be done
through a coursera but again it's going
to depend on the department and even
more than just the department approving
it you're going to want to make sure
that you feel comfortable tackling the
kinds of programming assignments that
are going to come up in in the more
advanced classes so um potentially
looking at the syllabi which are usually
available online for those courses to
really make sure that they're meeting
you know that
so
b103 109 uh those are all you can
probably find the syllabi from current
or previous classes available freely
online i would take a look at those and
just see what the assignments look like
see what the expectations are um and and
i think that will give you a sense
a i see about transferring units again
the masters anything about the master's
degree is going to come down to the
department um
you know and we we mentioned
yeah okay i think that's it we're at
time i know there are a few questions we
haven't answered i really appreciate
everyone joining thank you so much for
your time we hope this was useful uh
again go to the website there is an
inquiry form that we're linking to where
you can
where you can submit questions there's
also just a lot of information there and
uh you know we'd love to hear from you
and we'll be doing another version this
and we'll we'll be improving it we
really appreciate the feedback
all right thank you everybody